the Solus project takes place in a rich
science-fiction universe during the 22nd
century our solar system was ripped
apart by a rogue star and humanity
survives on a single fleet of spaceships
called the pro lyst colony in orbit
around Pluto with little fuel left and
starvation on the horizon pro less
command organizes a final desperate
mission to find a new home for Humanity
the operation is called the Solus
project in mankind's first intergalactic
venture five small scouting ships are
sent to five solar systems that are
suspected of having habitable planets
your craft tsp three has traveled for
more than a decade to a planet precious
little is known of just as you arrived
disaster strikes of the entire crew only
you survive as the only one left
mankind's survival depends on you is the
planet habitable is it safe while the
planet appears to have water and a
suitable atmosphere you'll quickly
uncover more than you ever expected on
Planet glee A's 6143 see a key part of
the solace experience is uncovering the
secrets of the planet's many islands and
caves players will uncover a legacy of
incredible structures and machinery you
search for the reason these aliens lived
on the planet why do they look like
humans and more importantly for your own
survival why did they die the Solus
project continues the plot of our
previous game the ball in the ball
players explored an alien structure
beneath a Mexican volcano in the 1940s
the Solus project picks up the same
story and style centuries later
you